a big part of my drive I've had Drive
always I was a dreamer I was the guy
that was you know but at the same time
the drive for Success came after a lot
of pain of course coming right
afterwards so that's why I'm asking you
a question so when that happened to you
did you fear risk of loving somebody was
kind of like I'll get this close to home
I got to move on no no no no I gotta
move on did that happen or no no I
wouldn't say that particularly happened
what would what did happen though like I
said earlier is when you have experience
with lots of different apples you know
what a good one a bad one is so when we
say we all had that girl we messed up
when we were young if I found another
girl with those qualities I certainly
wouldn't mess it up you just need you
need experience to understand what you
have to Value it if you don't have
experience you don't value what you have
so the original question is a really
good one of whether men are are chained
and enslaved by their desires or whether
they need to sleep with lots of women I
think in the modern world you need
experience and you need choices and you
need options but if you live by the
sword you die by the sword if you're
going to be the guy who's also out there
in the club and sleeping with those
girls talking to lots of girls there's
gonna be times you lose a girl that you
don't want to lose you can't be a coward
about it you live by the sword you die
by the sword there's up and down there's
rain and sunshine you have to be that
man who's going to go through it all and
then when you've been through enough of
it yeah like I have like I said if I
find a beautiful girl now who's a 10 and
deletes and doesn't want Instagram
that's worth more to me than a thousand
stupid girls yeah that's who I want I
got you for my safety
for everything you're clear on what you
want today absolutely because I know
when you when you played you said there
was a phase of my life that I kind of
went through it okay was that after the
Heartbreak
I would say yeah it was after but I
think that was just I I don't know if
that was deliberately driven by
heartbreak I think I was just younger
and I had less serious motivations and I
was less and I wasn't as famous and I
wasn't as rich and I was less interested
in
so
it's not just my current situation that
makes me say this I would say this to
any man
if your woman wouldn't wait for you if
you went to jail for five years why are
you with her
why if she wouldn't wait I know she's
hot I know she's funny I know she makes
you laugh but if you can't sit in that
jail cell with 100
certainty that she's not out with her
friends them in her ear talking [__]
watching Sex in the City whatever it is
and her ending up with some other guy
why are you even buying her dinner for
what sex
like that loyalty to me is the only
thing left that's valuable when I'm
interested we're in jail
we're sitting there saying we have so
much better than most guys
because most guys in jail imagine you're
a normal person you go to jail who's
feeding your family
who's paying the rent
who's feeding your kids I said Tristan
we're in jail we're suffering but
everybody we love is good
I'm a man I'm supposed to suffer I'll
sit here with the Cockroaches if that
means all my kids eat everyone I care
about eats my mother's fed my mother has
a house roof over her head everybody has
everything they want only person
suffering is me I'll take that all day
most men who go to jail can't say that
another thing that gave me absolute
peace of mind is the women who love me
are waiting for me imagine you go to
jail and you're completely heads over
heels in love with a woman but you know
deep in your heart that she's out in the
club and she's she's stealable you talk
about we talk about thoughts you can't
get out of your head
in jail it's amazing how when you lose
all access to electronics how thoughts
are Amplified
most of us sitting here you've never
been without a phone or without a laptop
or without computer for 93 days you'd be
amazed how loud you can think be amazed
how Vivid your mind is I learned that if
you had the nagging thought on your head
I loved her she cheated on me before
maybe she cheated again she hasn't
written me in three days and then plus
jail
that's why they're all crying that's why
all the men in there were sobbing
their wives are either [__] someone
else or the bills ain't paid it's not
just his situation it's everything else
so now if you're gonna say to me what do
I respect in a woman I respect the woman
who's gonna wait for me I have no
interest in a woman oh she's funny she's
cool she's hot don't care don't care is
she going to wait for me and I also know
because of my experience which one's
wood and which ones wouldn't I'm not
stupid because they'll all say they
would they'll all say don't wait because
they're on the jack but I know which
ones are lying because enough women have
lied to me I've seen it so you do need
that experience but once you have the
experience you start looking for
completely other things my neck is an
application which allows you to take a
minute to connect with influencers from
all around the world my name is Andrew
Tate and I'm available to speak directly
to you on minute so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]